Just a little girl, only 16 years old, isn't this something miraculous, wielding her weapons as though they weighed nothing at all? Indeed, she seems to have been raised for just such a moment, so strong she is and resolute. Her enemies stumble in flight before her Not one of them can stand up to her And all this she does before the gaze of the world She drives her foes out of France She recaptures castles and towns Never has anyone seen such formidable deeds
一个小女孩，年仅16岁，这难道不是奇迹吗？她挥舞着武器，仿佛它们轻如鸿毛。确实，她似乎就是为了这一刻而生的，她是如此坚强，如此果敢。她的敌人在她面前溃不成军，没有一个人能抵挡得住她。而这一切，她都是在全世界的注视下完成的。她将敌人赶出了法国，她收复了城堡和城镇，从未有人见过如此惊人的壮举。
Not hundreds, not thousands of men Can compare with her Of our brave and able warriors She is the chief captain. Neither Hector nor Achilles can rival her prowess. But it is God who has wrought this. God who leads her on. So that's a poem written in July 1429.
成百上千的人都无法与她相比。在我们勇敢能干的战士中，她是首席统帅。无论是赫克托耳还是阿喀琉斯，都无法与她的英勇相媲美。但这是上帝的杰作，是上帝在指引她。所以，这是一首写于1429年7月的诗。
It would astound people to know that that poem was written by a French woman, a French woman. One of the most remarkable women, according to Tom Holland, in medieval history. So she's often described as the first professional female writer in Western history. Her name was Christine de Bison. She was born in Venice, actually, so maybe I should have given her a little bit of an Italian lilt. But she came when she was four years old. Yeah, so she came to France. Her father was appointed the court astrologer, wasn't he?
如果人们知道这首诗是一位法国女性写的，一定会感到震惊。据汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland）所说，她是中世纪历史上最杰出的女性之一。她常被描述为西方历史上第一位职业女性作家。她的名字叫克里斯蒂娜·德·皮桑（Christine de Pizan）。她其实出生在威尼斯，所以也许我刚才应该带点意大利口音。但她四岁时就来到了法国。是的，她来到了法国。她的父亲被任命为宫廷占星家，不是吗？
So he was the Anthony Scaramucci, because he's a big fan of astrology. She was an Anthony Scaramucci, or the father was the Anthony Scaramucci of medieval history. And then in 1389, her husband dropped dead of the plague, Christine. She had three small children and a mother and a niece to support. And she turned to writing poetry. And in those days, actually, you could make money by writing poetry. So good for her. She made a fortune.
所以他就是那个时代的安东尼·斯卡拉穆奇（Anthony Scaramucci），因为他非常迷信占星术。她，或者说她的父亲，就是中世纪历史上的安东尼·斯卡拉穆奇。后来在1389年，她的丈夫死于瘟疫。克里斯蒂娜当时有三个年幼的孩子，还要供养母亲和侄女。于是她开始写诗。在那个年代，写诗确实是可以赚钱的。所以，这对她来说是件好事。她发了一笔财。
Yeah. She was prolific on a kind of Sandbrookian scale. So in 1405, she boasted that between the years 1399 and the present year, I have compiled 15 major works. Oh, that's good. But Dominic, that extract from the poem that you just read, that was the last poem she ever wrote. She wrote it in 1429. And it celebrated a girl who was even more famous, even more remarkable than she was, a girl that Christine called La Pusel, the maid, but who is best known today as, of course, Joan of Arc.
是的。她的作品非常多产，简直达到了“桑德布鲁克式”（Sandbrookian）的规模。1405年，她自豪地宣称，从1399年到今年，她已经编纂了15部主要著作。哦，那很不错。但是多米尼克，你刚才读的那段诗，那是她写过的最后一首诗。她写于1429年。这首诗歌颂了一位比她更出名、更了不起的女孩，克里斯蒂娜称她为“La Pucelle”，即“圣女”，但今天人们更熟悉的名字当然是圣女贞德。
Joan of Arc. So the most famous woman in medieval history, one of the most celebrated women who's ever existed, one of the most famous characters from medieval history of any gender who's existed. So if you think about, you've got a list here of all the people who've written songs about her, Leonard Cohen, Madonna, Kate Bush, Arcade Fire, Little Mix, the Cranberries. You mentioned one of my favorite bands, orchestral maneuvers in the dark. They actually wrote two, Joan of Arc and Maid of Orleans. Yeah, and they're both excellent.
圣女贞德。她是中世纪历史上最著名的女性，是有史以来最受赞誉的女性之一，也是中世纪历史上无论性别如何，最著名的人物之一。如果你想一下，这里有一份写过关于她的歌曲的人员名单：莱昂纳德·科恩（Leonard Cohen）、麦当娜（Madonna）、凯特·布什（Kate Bush）、拱廊之火乐队（Arcade Fire）、混合甜心组合（Little Mix）、小红莓乐队（The Cranberries）。你提到了我最喜欢的乐队之一，奥尔凯斯特拉机动部队（Orchestral Manoeuvres in the Dark）。他们实际上写了两首，分别是《圣女贞德》和《奥尔良少女》。是的，两首都非常出色。
Yeah, very good. And actually, one of them begins Little Catholic Girl, so quite like Christine's poem. I don't know whether they were influenced by her. Undoubtedly, they were. So she's a pop icon, isn't she, because she's a teenage girl, she's a rebel, she's an outsider. Well, she's doing things that teenage girls shouldn't do. And I think that understanding of her, that tradition, it begins with Christine, who is the author of the very first poem ever written.
是的，非常好。事实上，其中一首开头就是“小天主教女孩”，所以和克里斯蒂娜的诗很像。我不知道他们是否受到了她的影响。毫无疑问，他们肯定受到了影响。所以她是一个流行偶像，不是吗？因为她是一个十几岁的女孩，是一个叛逆者，是一个局外人。嗯，她在做十几岁女孩不该做的事情。我认为对她的这种理解，这种传统，始于克里斯蒂娜，她是历史上第一首关于贞德的诗的作者。
about Joan? Because, you know, that bit you read, what is Christine celebrating? She's celebrating the fact that, as you've implied, the English are losing and the French are winning. But more than that, she is celebrating the sheer, mad, glorious improbability of what she's describing that a little girl, only 16 years old, is leading an army into battle and what is more winning. Yeah. And the extraordinary thing, I mean, a couple of extraordinary things. She's so young. She's a girl, and she is a peasant girl. And to give people a sense who don't know anything about Joan of Arc, we're in the 15th century. It's the 100 years war. England have had it all their own way. So far, well, a lot of it, their own way. It looks like the English have won the 100 years war,
关于贞德？因为，你知道，你读的那部分，克里斯蒂娜在歌颂什么？正如你所暗示的，她在歌颂英国人正在失败，而法国人正在获胜的事实。但不仅如此，她还在歌颂她所描述的那种纯粹、疯狂、光荣的不可思议——一个年仅16岁的小女孩，正在率领军队投入战斗，而且更重要的是，她正在获胜。是的。而且最非凡的事情，我是说有几件非凡的事情。她太年轻了。她是个女孩，而且是个农家女孩。为了让那些对圣女贞德一无所知的人有个概念，我们现在处于15世纪。那是百年战争时期。英国人一直顺风顺水。到目前为止，嗯，很大程度上，他们一直顺风顺水。看起来英国人已经赢得了百年战争。
that, you know, we've ended the last series about it with Achencore and Henry V and his great victories. And now this is going to be the great turnaround in French history. And as you say in your notes, Tom, it feels like something less from the pages of history than from the pages of either fantasy, George R. R. R. Martin or something, or indeed a fairy tale. Yeah, because this is a girl who claims that she has been ordered by supernatural voices to save France, and she puts on male dress, and she rides to the distant court of the king, and the king amazingly agrees to meet her, and is persuaded by her, that she has this God-given mission to defeat the king's enemies and to see him crowned.
你知道，我们上一季是以阿金库尔战役和亨利五世的伟大胜利结束的。而现在，这将是法国历史上伟大的转折点。正如你在笔记中所说，汤姆，这感觉不像是历史书页上的内容，而更像是奇幻小说，比如乔治·R·R·马丁的作品，或者确实是一个童话故事。是的，因为这是一个女孩，她声称自己受到超自然声音的指引去拯救法国，她穿上男装，骑马前往遥远的国王宫廷，而国王竟然同意接见她，并被她说服，相信她肩负着上帝赋予的使命，去击败国王的敌人并见证他的加冕。
And she then rides in armour like a knight at the head of a great army. She liberates the famous city of Orleans on the River Loire from a siege. She then leads the king through enemy territory, and she does indeed succeed in crowning him in a distant cathedral in a city set amid hostile territory. She is then captured, she's put on trial, she is convicted of heresy, and notoriously, she is burnt to death. And it is one of, if not the most extraordinary stories of the whole of history. And I think we're so familiar with it that perhaps you need to kind of do a deep dive to remind yourself of just how astonishing the story is. And the thing is that even the greatest of historians have struggled to make sense of her, to make sense of her story.
然后她像骑士一样身披盔甲，率领一支大军。她从围困中解放了卢瓦尔河畔著名的奥尔良城。随后，她带领国王穿过敌占区，并确实成功地让他在敌方领土中心的一座遥远大教堂里加冕。随后她被俘，接受审判，被判处异端罪，并臭名昭著地被活活烧死。这是整个历史上最非凡的故事之一，如果不是最非凡的话。我认为我们对它太熟悉了，以至于你可能需要深入挖掘，才能提醒自己这个故事是多么令人震惊。问题在于，即使是最伟大的历史学家也难以理解她，难以理解她的故事。
So have you read the waning of the Middle Ages? Yeah, Johann Heisinger. Yeah, it was so great Dutch historian and published in 1990. And in his study of 15th century, Burgundy and Northern France, he pointedly omitted Joan, even though she is probably the most famous character from that period. And this wasn't because he thought that she was unimportant, but absolutely the opposite. So he wrote about it years later, why he had admitted Joan. I knew that she would have torn the book I visualized in my mind completely out of balance. What kept me from introducing her in it was a sense of harmony, that and a vast
那么你读过《中世纪的衰落》吗？是的，约翰·赫伊津哈（Johan Huizinga）。是的，那是伟大的荷兰历史学家，出版于1919年。在他对15世纪勃艮第和法国北部的研究中，他特意省略了贞德，尽管她可能是那个时期最著名的人物。这并不是因为他认为她不重要，恰恰相反。多年后他写道，为什么他没有写贞德：我知道她会把我脑海中构思的那本书完全破坏平衡。让我没有在书中介绍她的原因是一种和谐感，那是一种广阔的……
and reverent humility. And he said of her that she is a figure more beautiful than any other nation possesses. And that's a Dutchman. That's a Dutchman. But of course, not everybody has agreed with that verdict, have they, Tom? Because even at the time, there were a lot of people who, in fact, especially at the time, there are a lot of people who took a very different view of La Pucel, the maid of Orleans. And chief among them were a people we've already mentioned who were, of course, the English.
和虔诚的谦卑。他评价她说，她是一个比任何其他国家所拥有的都更美丽的形象。那可是个荷兰人。那可是个荷兰人。但当然，并非所有人都同意这个结论，对吧，汤姆？因为即使在当时，也有很多人，事实上，特别是在当时，有很多人对“La Pucelle”，即奥尔良少女，有着非常不同的看法。其中最主要的就是我们已经提到过的人，当然就是英国人。
So they absolutely loathed and indeed feared her, didn't they, as not merely a, you know, mortal enemy, but as a kind of supernatural enemy, right? Sorcerous, a witch. Yeah, so here is the Duke of Bedford, who was the regent for his infant nephew, Henry the 6th, during this period. And he's summing up the maid only a week after Christine de Pizain had completed her poem. And his take is very different to Christine's. Bedford says of her, she is a loose, infamous and immoral woman dressed as a man.
所以他们绝对厌恶，甚至害怕她，不是吗？不仅仅把她看作一个凡人的敌人，而是看作一种超自然的敌人，对吧？巫婆，女巫。是的，这就是贝德福德公爵（Duke of Bedford），他在这一时期担任他那年幼的侄子亨利六世的摄政王。他在克里斯蒂娜·德·皮桑完成诗作仅一周后，就对这位少女进行了总结。他的看法与克里斯蒂娜截然不同。贝德福德评价她说：她是一个穿着男装的放荡、卑劣且不道德的女人。
And he can't leave it alone because five years later, he's still at it. And he is directly blaming the decline of English fortunes in France on this monstrous sorceress, a disciple and limb of the fiend called the Pussell that used false enchantment and sorcery. And the reason he is simmering, smouldering with rage is that this, you know, her life and her rise to prominence coincides with the turning point in this long-running struggle between England and France in the 14th and 15th centuries that comes to be called the Hundred Years' War. We've done, you know, a long-running series on it. A couple of seasons, haven't we?
而且他对此念念不忘，因为五年后，他还在这么说。他直接将英国在法国的命运衰落归咎于这个怪物般的巫婆，一个被称为“圣女”的恶魔的门徒和爪牙，她使用了虚假的魔法和巫术。他之所以怒火中烧，是因为她的生活和她的崛起，恰逢英法两国在14和15世纪这场长期斗争的转折点，也就是后来被称为“百年战争”的时期。我们已经做过关于它的长期系列节目了。做了好几季，不是吗？
We're now coming to the decisive moment. And that's one reason why Christine de Pizant celebrates Joan so much is that, as Christine puts it, Joan will cast down the English for good, for this is what God wishes. And this really is a turning point in their history of the intermingual relations between England and France. I'm sorry to say I have to warn our listeners. I don't normally agree with trigger warnings, but in this case, I do. The English will not come off well in this story.
我们现在正来到决定性的时刻。这也是克里斯蒂娜·德·皮桑如此歌颂贞德的一个原因，正如克里斯蒂娜所言，贞德将彻底击败英国人，因为这是上帝的意愿。这确实是英法两国关系史上的一个转折点。我很抱歉，我必须提醒我们的听众。我通常不同意设置触发警告，但在这种情况下，我同意。英国人在这个故事中不会有什么好下场。
So this is basically Theo Heaven. It's four episodes of the English behaving both badly and losing. And Dominic, I'm sure you would join with me in dedicating this series to Theo on that account. So it's the story of how the English come to lose once and for all the 100 years war. But I think before that we should cheer our English. listeners up by repriezing everything that had gone right for England. So how they had come to invade France, how they'd come to conquer a lot of it, how they came to seem actually on the verge of winning the war outright. Obviously, the English, unlike Joan, unlike Christine,
所以这基本上是“西奥的天堂”（Theo Heaven）。这是四集关于英国人表现糟糕且不断失败的内容。多米尼克，我相信你会和我一起把这个系列献给西奥。所以，这是关于英国人如何最终输掉百年战争的故事。但我认为在此之前，我们应该重温一下英国人曾经取得的所有成就，来振奋一下我们英国听众的精神。比如他们是如何入侵法国的，如何征服了大部分领土，以及他们是如何看起来真的处于彻底赢得战争的边缘。显然，英国人不像贞德，不像克里斯蒂娜，
do not think they're the baddies. They think that the French throne rightfully belongs to their king, and that a succession of astonishing victories has comprehensively demonstrated the fact that God agrees with this, because otherwise, if the English were not justified in invading France, God wouldn't have allowed them to win so many victories over the French. A crucial point here is that England is much smaller and much less populous and much less rich than France. So England is the underdog. I think when we started the Hundred Years' War series. We compared it to Ukraine versus Russia. You know, one giant, one Beemoth, and a much smaller country that has actually in this case launched a preemptive strike, basically as a
他们不认为自己是坏人。他们认为法国王位理应属于他们的国王，而且一系列惊人的胜利已经全面证明了这一点，因为如果英国人入侵法国是不正义的，上帝就不会允许他们在对阵法国人时取得如此多的胜利。这里的一个关键点是，英国比法国小得多，人口少得多，也富裕得多。所以英国是弱势的一方。我想当我们开始百年战争系列时，我们把它比作乌克兰对阵俄罗斯。你知道，一个巨人，一个庞然大物，而另一个小得多的国家，实际上在这种情况下发动了先发制人的打击，基本上是作为一种……
defensive measure, and has enjoyed extraordinary success beyond the wildest dreams, you know, you would think, of England's kings. And England has done very well, and the two kings in particular. So one is Edward III, the victor of Cressy and Poitiers, the great kind of Royster-doister of English history, and the other is Henry the 5th. So he has won a tremendous victory at the Battle of Agincourt, but then he dies. So at the point of his success, at the point at his peak, right, he's become, he's a dominant figure in France, isn't he? Yeah, he's the leading military figure in the whole of Europe. And if you want to hear the story of Henry V, we did a series on it a year or so ago, and that is episodes 487 and the next three.
防御措施，并且享受到了超出英国国王最狂野梦想的非凡成功。英国做得非常好，特别是两位国王。一位是爱德华三世，克雷西和普瓦捷战役的胜利者，英国历史上伟大的“狂欢者”；另一位是亨利五世。他在阿金库尔战役中取得了巨大的胜利，但随后他就去世了。所以在他成功的时刻，在他巅峰的时刻，对吧，他已经成为了法国的主导人物，不是吗？是的，他是整个欧洲领先的军事人物。如果你想听亨利五世的故事，我们一年前左右做过一个系列，那是第487集以及接下来的三集。
But it's not just the military genius of Henry that had enabled England to impose itself against all the odds on France. So it also has a very elaborate, centralized framework of government. And this means that under an effective king, the English state is able to kind of raise taxes and recruit troops and provision armies much more effectively than the French king can because in France, the kingdom is kind of divided up into all kinds of different dukedoms and counties and so on. The other advantage that Henry V has in invading France is an incredibly effective military machine, and it's strength-lise in infantry rather than the cavalry that the French tend to prefer. And it's a kind of mix of men at arms and longbowmen and longbows
但不仅仅是亨利的军事天才使英国能够克服重重困难在法国立足。它还有一个非常复杂、集权的政府框架。这意味着在一位有效的国王领导下，英国国家能够比法国国王更有效地征税、招募军队和供应军队，因为在法国，王国被分割成各种各样的公国和郡县等等。亨利五世入侵法国的另一个优势是一台极其有效的军事机器，它的力量在于步兵，而不是法国人倾向于偏爱的骑兵。这是一种由武装人员和长弓手组成的混合体，而长弓……
traditionally are seen by the English as absolutely what gives them the cutting edge. So a generation later, Sir John Fortescue, kind of leading analyst of the age. He says, The power of England standeth most upon our poor archers. And the great demonstration of this was in 1415 at Agincourt, when the French slaughtered as if they were cattle, according to one English Chronicle, the French High Command, the cream of the nobility, decapitated, loads of them perish on the battlefield, a key figure who will be coming back to, an important somebody to remember the Duke of Alonsohn. So he was the commander of the second of the two French divisions and he had all these holdings in Normandy which now passed to his six-year-old heir
传统上被英国人视为赋予他们优势的关键。所以一代人之后，约翰·福特斯丘爵士（Sir John Fortescue），那个时代的领先分析家，他说：“英国的力量主要在于我们贫穷的弓箭手。”而这最伟大的证明是在1415年的阿金库尔，当时法国人像牲畜一样被屠杀，据一位英国编年史家记载，法国的高级指挥官，贵族中的精英，被斩首，许多人在战场上丧生，一个我们将要回到的关键人物，一个需要记住的重要人物——阿朗松公爵（Duke of Alençon）。他是两个法国师中第二个师的指挥官，他在诺曼底拥有所有这些领地，现在传给了他六岁的继承人……
and they are now very vulnerable, aren't they? So people should remember that. That six-year-old heir he will be featuring later in this story. And also as well as the slaughter, there maybe up to 2,000 French noblemen are captured. And the most distinguished of these is the French King's nephew, the Duke of O'Leon, because his title is one of the highest ranking in France. He gets taken to England where he is destined to spend years and years in captivity. And again, we mention him because the city of O'Leon and the Ducal family of O'Ollior will be playing a key role in Jones' story. Okay.
他们现在非常脆弱，不是吗？所以人们应该记住这一点。那个六岁的继承人，他稍后会出现在这个故事中。而且除了屠杀之外，可能有多达2000名法国贵族被俘。其中最显赫的是法国国王的侄子，奥尔良公爵（Duke of Orléans），因为他的头衔是法国最高级别的头衔之一。他被带到英国，注定要在囚禁中度过漫长的岁月。同样，我们提到他，是因为奥尔良城和奥尔良公爵家族将在贞德的故事中扮演关键角色。好的。
So Achencore, tremendous victory. Two years later, Henry V comes back to France, and he cuts a sway through Normandy, one of the places that he systematically absorbs is Alonsohn, which as we described, has fallen to this six-year-old air. Yeah, so he's lost all his inheritance, basically. Exactly. By 1419, Henry has taken Ruehl, the chief city of Normandy. He now commands the upper River Sen. That means that basically Paris is vulnerable.
所以阿金库尔，巨大的胜利。两年后，亨利五世回到法国，他在诺曼底横扫千军，他系统性吸收的地方之一就是阿朗松，正如我们所描述的，它已经落入了那个六岁的继承人手中。是的，所以他基本上失去了所有的遗产。没错。到1419年，亨利已经占领了诺曼底的首府鲁昂。他现在控制了塞纳河上游。这意味着基本上巴黎已经变得脆弱。
And not only has Henry got the wind in his sails, but the Frenchman. an utter chaos and shambles, aren't they? Because basically France has descended into anarchy. Yeah. So proficient to commander though, Henry is there is no way I think that he could have been as successful as he turned out to be. Had France been ordered, had it not been racked essentially by a really, really violent civil war? And it is so French that the rival factions in the civil war, one of them is named after probably France's greatest wine-growing region. And the other is named after brandy. So it's Burgundy against Armagnac. And it's Burgundy because the greatest of all the Dukes in France is the Duke of Burgundy.
而且亨利不仅顺风顺水，法国人也陷入了彻底的混乱和瘫痪，不是吗？因为基本上法国已经陷入了无政府状态。是的。亨利确实是一位精明的指挥官，但我认为如果法国秩序井然，如果它没有被一场非常、非常暴力的内战所折磨，他不可能取得如此大的成功。而且这非常法国化，内战中的敌对派系，其中一个是以法国可能最伟大的葡萄酒产区命名的。而另一个是以白兰地命名的。所以这是勃艮第对阵阿马尼亚克（Armagnac）。这是勃艮第，因为法国所有公爵中最伟大的是勃艮第公爵。
And at the time of Henry V's invasion, this is a guy called John the Fearless. He has loads of holdings in the east of France, including obviously Burgundy. So he's a vassal of the French king. But he also has loads of holdings in the low countries. and so he's also a vassal of the Holy Roman Emperor. And that means that he kind of has an independence from France that other nobleman in the kingdom tend not to have. And this provokes all kinds of envy and resentment. None of these rival peers individually can compare with the authority of the Duke of Burgundy.
在亨利五世入侵时，这是一个叫“无畏者约翰”（John the Fearless）的人。他在法国东部拥有大量领地，显然包括勃艮第。所以他是法国国王的附庸。但他也在低地国家拥有大量领地，所以他也是神圣罗马皇帝的附庸。这意味着他拥有一种法国其他贵族往往没有的独立性。这引发了各种嫉妒和怨恨。这些敌对的同僚中，没有一个人能单独与勃艮第公爵的权威相提并论。
But if they all gang up, then they are kind of, you know, they measure up to him. And the guy who takes the lead in kind of forming them into a posse is a guy called the count of Armagnac. And so this is why you get these two rival factions, the Burgundians and the Arminiaks. And they start kind of tearing each other to pieces. And to begin with, it looks like the Armeniaks have the upper hand. And this is because they hold two cards. The first, they hold Paris. So the capital of France, the Duke of Burgundy and his supporters have been expelled from the capital, but they also have the backing of the Dauphin, so the heir to the French throne. He's a guy called Charles. He's 16 years old. He's very sickly. He's very
但如果他们联合起来，那么他们就……你知道，他们就能与他抗衡。而带头将他们组成一个团伙的人是一个叫阿马尼亚克伯爵（Count of Armagnac）的人。所以这就是为什么你会得到这两个敌对派系，勃艮第派和阿马尼亚克派。他们开始互相残杀。起初，看起来阿马尼亚克派占了上风。这是因为他们手中有两张牌。第一，他们控制着巴黎。所以法国的首都，勃艮第公爵和他的支持者被赶出了首都，但他们也有王储（Dauphin）的支持，也就是法国王位的继承人。他叫查理。他16岁。他非常体弱多病。他非常……
moody. He has no great self-confidence. He has very spindly legs. And essentially, I think even at the age of 16, he has a slight look of Vladimir Putin, only with very rubbery lips. And the reason that he's been cast in the spotlight is his father has gone completely mad, hasn't he? Yes, so Charles is sixth. So then there's a big twist, isn't there? An amazing twist. I remember seeing an illustration of this when I was a boy of all of these kind of illustrated book about all this stuff. And I loved it.
喜怒无常。他没有太大的自信。他的腿非常细长。基本上，我认为即使在16岁时，他也有点像弗拉基米尔·普京，只是嘴唇非常厚。他之所以被推到聚光灯下，是因为他的父亲已经完全疯了，不是吗？是的，查理六世。所以接下来有一个大转折，不是吗？一个惊人的转折。我记得我小时候看过一张关于这一切的插图，是一本关于所有这些事情的插图本。我非常喜欢它。
So Burgundian troops in 1419 get into Paris. They batter the count of Armagnac to death. They carve his cross, his sultire, from his coat of arms into his flesh. That's a nice detail. There's then a huge pogrom of the Armaniacs. The Dove found the heir to the French throne, basically young Vladimir Putin. He has to be smuggled out of Paris, and he sets up a court in Bourge in central France, which is south of the Loire.
1419年，勃艮第军队进入巴黎。他们把阿马尼亚克伯爵打死。他们把他的十字架，他的斜十字纹章，从他的外套上刻进他的肉里。那是个不错的细节。随后发生了针对阿马尼亚克派的大屠杀。王储，法国王位的继承人，基本上就是年轻的弗拉基米尔·普京。他不得不被偷运出巴黎，并在法国中部的布尔日（Bourges）建立了一个宫廷，那里在卢瓦尔河以南。
So that's the context. Well, Henry V from England, he's thinking, yeah, it's all his Christmases, come at once. Yeah, he's advancing from the north. And actually, he gets to the city's gates, doesn't he, not long after this, a few months after this in August 1419. And then there's another amazing twist, which is the head of the Burgundians, John the Fearless, and the Dauphin, agreed to meet. And this is one of my favorite summit meetings in all history. Yes. And it is one of the most notorious episodes and consequential episodes in French history. Yeah. So this summit is held on the 10th of September on a bridge at Montreux,
这就是背景。嗯，来自英国的亨利五世，他心想，是的，他所有的圣诞愿望都一次实现了。是的，他从北方推进。事实上，他没过多久就到达了城门，不是吗？几个月后的1419年8月。然后又有一个惊人的转折，那就是勃艮第派的首领“无畏者约翰”和王储同意会面。这是我历史上最喜欢的峰会之一。是的。这是法国历史上最臭名昭著和后果深远的事件之一。是的。所以这次峰会于9月10日在蒙特罗（Montereau）的一座桥上举行，
which is some 50 miles southeast of Paris, so essentially between Paris and Borge. So it's kind of neutral territory. And the bridge again is designed to be a neutral space. The problem is, it all goes wrong because John the fearless, the Duke of Burgundy, is assassinated by the Dauphin's men, right? So it seems. And certainly, whether the Dauphin personally is responsible for it or not, the son of the Duke of Burgundy, who is now the Duke of Burgundy himself,
距离巴黎东南约50英里，所以基本上是在巴黎和布尔日之间。所以这是一种中立领土。而这座桥的设计也是为了成为一个中立空间。问题是，一切都搞砸了，因为勃艮第公爵“无畏者约翰”被王储的人暗杀了，对吧？看起来是这样。当然，无论王储本人是否对此负责，勃艮第公爵的儿子，现在他自己也是勃艮第公爵了，
Philip, who is known as Philip the Good, he blames the Dauphin for the murder of his father. And this means that the blood feud between the Burgundians and the Arminiacs is now absolutely entrenched to the degree that Philip the Good, you know, his father's body is bleeding. Rather than combine with the Dauphin against Henry V and the English, Philip the Good now goes to Henry VIII and he signs up to an English alliance. Craig here, this is a twist. So the result of this, basically, is that things are looking terrible for the French because the Burgundians and the English have joined forces.
菲利普，被称为“好人菲利普”（Philip the Good），他指责王储谋杀了他父亲。这意味着勃艮第派和阿马尼亚克派之间的血海深仇现在已经彻底根深蒂固，以至于“好人菲利普”，你知道，他父亲的尸体还在流血。他没有与王储联合起来对抗亨利五世和英国人，“好人菲利普”现在去找亨利五世，并签署了英勃联盟。克雷格，这是一个转折。所以这基本上导致法国的情况看起来非常糟糕，因为勃艮第人和英国人联手了。
And so the following May, basically the French, they kind of have to yield to the inevitable, don't they? Well, the king does. So Charles VI, who is by this point a kind of a race-like spectre, completely mad. And so therefore essentially a puppet of the Duke of Burgundy. He is in the city of Tois, in Champagne, which is kind of southeast of Paris. Henry V joins Philip and Charles VIx there, and they draw up a treaty. And by the terms of this treaty, Charles XVI remains on the French throne until he dies.
所以第二年五月，基本上法国人，他们不得不屈服于不可避免的事实，不是吗？嗯，国王确实屈服了。所以查理六世，此时已经是一个像幽灵一样的人，完全疯了。因此，他本质上是勃艮第公爵的傀儡。他在香槟地区的特鲁瓦（Troyes）市，那里在巴黎的东南方。亨利五世在那里与菲利普和查理六世会合，他们起草了一份条约。根据这份条约的条款，查理六世在去世前仍保留法国王位。
Henry will rule as his regent, and he will marry Charles X's daughter, Catherine. On the death of Charles VI, the French crown will pass to Henry and his heirs. So Henry of Lancaster, so to the House of Lancaster. And the House of Lancaster will take the place on the French throne of Charles VI's own dynasty, the House of Valois. And once England and France have come under the rule of the House of Lancaster, they will be separate kingdoms, but they will be joined under one crown. And there will be peace and amity and all will be well. And this is the plan. This is one of the questions we're asked most often at live shows and bonus.
亨利将担任摄政王，并将迎娶查理六世的女儿凯瑟琳。查理六世去世后，法国王位将传给亨利及其继承人。所以兰开斯特的亨利，也就是兰开斯特王朝。兰开斯特王朝将取代查理六世自己的王朝——瓦卢瓦王朝，登上法国王位。一旦英国和法国处于兰开斯特王朝的统治之下，它们将是独立的王国，但它们将联合在一个王冠之下。将会有和平与友谊，一切都会好起来的。这就是计划。这是我们在现场演出和“历史俱乐部”奖励剧集中最常被问到的问题之一。
episodes of the rest of history club? What would have, if Henry V had lived, would England and France have become one kingdom? And in a way, I think this series answers that question. Yeah, I think it does. But in the meanwhile, obviously for the Dauphin, Charles 6th son, who's now just been disinherited, this is terrible news because he's been publicly condemned by his own father as a murderer. You know, he's been bumped off the line of inheritance. And he has no prospect, really, of defeating Henry V, partly because Henry VIII is the greatest warrior of the age, but also because the Dofair can't risk himself in battle, because without him, the House of Valois really would be extinct. There is no one else to keep the Valois line
如果亨利五世活着，英国和法国会成为一个王国吗？在某种程度上，我认为这个系列回答了那个问题。是的，我想确实如此。但与此同时，显然对于王储，查理六世的儿子，他现在刚刚被剥夺了继承权，这是一个可怕的消息，因为他已经被他自己的父亲公开谴责为杀人犯。你知道，他已经被踢出了继承序列。而且他真的没有击败亨利五世的希望，部分是因为亨利五世是那个时代最伟大的战士，但也因为王储不能让自己冒险上战场，因为没有他，瓦卢瓦王朝真的会灭绝。没有其他人能维持瓦卢瓦血统……
going. And then things get even worse, because on the 6th of December 1421, Henry and his new bride, so the sister of the Dofair, Catherine, Catherine gives Henry the 5th, not just a child but a son whom they'd call the great originality Henry the future Henry the 6th and so this means that the House of Lancaster now has an heir and so a lot of people in France it's important to if we stop the clock there December 1421 France is an anarchy the English have taken advantage taking Paris all of this Henry is the regent now he expects to be king he has a son ready if you're sitting there in France, you look at this and you say, well, this is how it's going
继续下去。然后情况变得更糟，因为1421年12月6日，亨利和他的新婚妻子，也就是王储的妹妹凯瑟琳，凯瑟琳给了亨利五世一个孩子，不仅是一个孩子，还是一个儿子，他们称他为——极具原创性——亨利，未来的亨利六世。所以这意味着兰开斯特王朝现在有了继承人。所以法国的许多人，如果我们把时钟停在那里，1421年12月，法国处于无政府状态，英国人利用了这一点，占领了巴黎，所有这些，亨利现在是摄政王，他期望成为国王，他有一个儿子准备好了。如果你坐在法国，你看着这一切，你会说，好吧，事情就是这样了。
to be. And this is God's plan. This is obviously what God wants. And so when people work with Henry, they're not doing so because they're, you know, proto-martial paint hands or something. It's not a question of sort of cowardly collaboration. It's because they genuinely look at the situation. They say, this is all part of the divine workings out of, you know, of God's intention for the world. I think also there's a certain grudging respect for Henry V. He's a serious person. You know, he, this is a guy who could kind of lick a crumbling kingdom into shape. But also, I think for lots of people in France who decide to back the House of Lancaster,
这是上帝的计划。这显然是上帝想要的。所以当人们与亨利合作时，他们这样做并不是因为他们是，你知道，某种“原始贝当”（proto-Pétain）式的卖国贼。这不是一种懦弱的合作问题。这是因为他们真诚地审视了局势。他们说，这一切都是上帝对世界意图的某种神圣运作的一部分。我认为人们对亨利五世也有某种勉强的尊重。他是一个严肃的人。你知道，他是一个能把一个分崩离析的王国带回正轨的人。但我也认为，对于法国许多决定支持兰开斯特王朝的人来说，
it's not really about the English at all. It's about what your identity is in the civil war. So if you back the Arminiaks, you're never going to accept this. But if you are a Burgundian sympathizer, then you absolutely are. So in a sense, it's, it's, it's simultaneous. Obviously, the Hundred Years' War and the Civil War between the Burgundians and the Army Acts have become interfused. And this explains why so many people in France are willing to accept the House of Lancaster
这其实根本不是关于英国人的。这是关于你在内战中身份认同的问题。所以如果你支持阿马尼亚克派，你永远不会接受这一点。但如果你是一个勃艮第派的同情者，那么你绝对会接受。所以从某种意义上说，它是同时发生的。显然，百年战争和勃艮第派与阿马尼亚克派之间的内战已经融合在一起了。这就解释了为什么法国有这么多人愿意接受兰开斯特王朝，
as a legitimate replacement for the House of Valois. And Theo has actually made a good point in the chat, which is that, you know, the English and French ruling classes are so similar. You know, in their devotion to the ideals of chivalry, in their devotion to kind of the stuff about Courtney Love, you know, the use of French, all of that stuff, that it doesn't necessarily feel like you're accepting the rule of kind of foreign barbarians, right? I'm not sure that is entirely true, because this is the first century, really, in which the English aristocracy are not speaking French as their native language.
作为瓦卢瓦王朝的合法替代者。西奥在聊天中提出了一个很好的观点，那就是，你知道，英国和法国的统治阶级非常相似。你知道，他们对骑士精神理想的奉献，对宫廷爱情的奉献，对法语的使用，所有这些东西，这并不一定让你觉得你在接受某种外国野蛮人的统治，对吧？我不确定这是否完全正确，因为这是英国贵族不再以法语为母语的第一个世纪。
Oh, interesting. So it is noted as something exceptional when an English aristocrat speaks very good French, as we will see. Here's a quick question then. In other words, if this had happened a century or two earlier, the outcome might have been different. It might indeed. But as it is, there are obviously lots of very distinguished, very clear thinking Frenchmen who are prepared to accept the House of Lancaster. And just plucking at random an example, let's look at one.
哦，有趣。所以当一位英国贵族说一口非常好的法语时，这被视为一种例外，正如我们将要看到的。那么这里有一个快速的问题。换句话说，如果这发生在早一两个世纪，结果可能会有所不同。确实可能。但事实是，显然有很多非常杰出、头脑非常清醒的法国人准备接受兰开斯特王朝。让我们随便举个例子，看看其中一个。
So he is a very distinguished churchman and he goes by the name of Pierre Couchon. He'd been born in Arras, city to the north of. Paris, where by ancient tradition, the kings of France were always crowned. This is where Clovis, the very first king of the Franks to accept Christianity, had been baptized. Couchon had then gone to Paris to study at the university there, which is the greatest center for theology in the whole of Europe. And there, as a student, he had become a very enthusiastic partisan of the Burgundian cause, hates the Arminiacs. He's appointed the bishop of Beauvais, which is a city in Champagne, about 50 miles northwest of Paris. So his center of gravity is very much that kind of
他是一位非常杰出的教会人士，名字叫皮埃尔·科雄（Pierre Cauchon）。他出生在阿拉斯（Arras），那是巴黎以北的一座城市，根据古老的传统，法国国王总是在那里加冕。这就是克洛维（Clovis），第一位接受基督教的法兰克国王受洗的地方。科雄随后前往巴黎，在当地大学学习，那是整个欧洲最伟大的神学中心。在那里，作为一名学生，他成为了勃艮第事业的狂热支持者，痛恨阿马尼亚克派。他被任命为博韦（Beauvais）的主教，那是一座位于香槟地区的城市，在巴黎西北约50英里处。所以他的重心非常偏向于那种……
region, Paris and the region between Paris and the low countries where Burgundy, you know, has his center of gravity. And Caution is very, very devoutly convinced that only the Anglo-Bagundian Alliance has any prospect of stabilizing France. And so he goes full in. And I think it is unfair to think, you know, you mentioned Marshall Paita. This is not a vicious policy. I think in the context of the time, it's entirely understandable. A quick note for listeners, they should remember this bloke, Pierre Couchon, and his support for this alliance and his role in this story. Just keep him in your heads as you listen to this series because he will play a very, very significant role. In the way that if you're reading a detective story and it's mentioned in chapter two that there's
地区，巴黎以及巴黎和低地国家之间的地区，勃艮第在那里拥有他的重心。科雄非常虔诚地相信，只有英勃联盟才有稳定法国的希望。所以他全力以赴。我认为认为这是一种恶毒的政策是不公平的，你提到了贝当元帅。我认为在当时的背景下，这是完全可以理解的。给听众一个快速提示，他们应该记住这个家伙，皮埃尔·科雄，以及他对这个联盟的支持和他在这个故事中的角色。在听这个系列时，请记住他，因为他将扮演一个非常、非常重要的角色。就像如果你在读侦探小说，第二章提到壁炉架上有一把枪，你可以相当肯定那把枪在某个时候会走火。
a gun on the mantelpiece, you can be fairly confident that gun is going to go off at some point. going to go off. So Couchon is kind of representative of those who side with the House of Lancaster. Obviously, there are lots in France who think this is appalling, a disgrace, a humiliation. And one of them is Christine de Pizin, very loyal to the royal family. You know, she'd been raised in the court. And she is so upset by what has happened that this incredibly articulate, prolific poet just fall silent. And in 1418, she retires to an abbey where her daughter was a nun and she never she doesn't write anything else um so there are lots of other people who were recording the horrors of the age so that you know the hunger the brutality
会走火。所以科雄是那些站在兰开斯特王朝一边的人的代表。显然，法国有很多人认为这令人震惊、是一种耻辱、是一种羞辱。其中之一就是克里斯蒂娜·德·皮桑，她对王室非常忠诚。你知道，她是在宫廷里长大的。她对所发生的事情感到非常难过，以至于这位极其善于表达、多产的诗人陷入了沉默。1418年，她隐退到了一座修道院，她的女儿在那里当修女，她再也没有写过任何其他东西。所以还有许多其他人记录了那个时代的恐怖，你知道，饥饿、残暴，
the wolves padding through the outskirts of paris all this kind of stuff but christine is so appalled it's like she's gone into a kind of catatonic shop doesn't doesn't speak at all but then the tom there's there are more twists in this very uh georgia romartan style story so first of all August 1422, Henry V, 5th, dies unexpectedly young. Yes, so he never sits on the French throne. And then the guy who is on the French throne, this sort of mad puppet, Charles the 6th, he dies two months after that. So now they're at the equation.
狼群在巴黎郊区徘徊，所有这些事情，但克里斯蒂娜感到非常震惊，就像她陷入了一种紧张性精神症。她根本不说话。但随后，汤姆，在这个非常“乔治·R·R·马丁”风格的故事中还有更多的转折。首先，1422年8月，亨利五世意外早逝。是的，所以他从未坐上法国王位。然后，那个坐在法国王位上的傀儡，那个疯子查理六世，在两个月后去世了。所以现在方程变了。
The new king of France, according to the treaty, will be Henry VIII's infant son, Henri II of France or Henry the 6th of England but he's a baby so what now for the English well they're not going to give up on Henry the Fifth's dream and there is a deep personal sense of obligation to Henry the Fifth you know all the hard men in the English government had fought with him had been at Agencourt and Normandy they are absolutely committed to basically to fulfilling this treaty that Henry had done so much to draw up. And this is where the Duke of Bedford, who we have already mentioned before, comes in, John of Lancaster, the Duke of Bedford. He is Henry V's younger brother. He is therefore
根据条约，法国的新国王将是亨利五世的幼子，法国的亨利二世或英国的亨利六世，但他是个婴儿。那么英国人现在该怎么办？好吧，他们不会放弃亨利五世的梦想，而且对亨利五世有一种深沉的个人义务感。你知道，英国政府中所有的硬汉都曾与他并肩作战，都曾在阿金库尔和诺曼底战斗过。他们绝对致力于基本上完成亨利为之付出如此多努力而起草的这份条约。这就是我们之前提到过的贝德福德公爵（Duke of Bedford）登场的地方，兰开斯特的约翰，贝德福德公爵。他是亨利五世的弟弟。因此他是……
the uncle of Henry the 6th. And in France, he is going to serve the infant, Henry the 6th, as regent. So effectively, in France, he is now the head of this kind of Anglo-Bugundian alliance. And he is a proper person, right? He's not something. I mean, he is, people may be anticipating because they know the English are going to lose. He's a waste of space. Not at all. He is an experienced captain. He's a sensible guy.
亨利六世的叔叔。在法国，他将作为摄政王为婴儿亨利六世服务。所以实际上，在法国，他现在是这种英勃联盟的首脑。他是一个正派的人，对吧？他不是……我的意思是，人们可能因为知道英国人会输而预料到他是一个废物。一点也不。他是一位经验丰富的统帅。他是一个明智的人。
He's, he's scary. He ticks every box. Yeah. So there's a churchman in Rouen, which along with Paris is one of the kind of the two major centres of English power in France. And this churchman says of Bedford, wise and generous at once feared and loved. And there's a brilliant observation by John. Jonathan Sumpion in the last of his enormous volumes on the Hundred Years' War. And he says that Bedford maintained a standing army in France, to quote Sumpion,
他很可怕。他符合所有条件。是的。鲁昂有一位教会人士，那里和巴黎一样，是英国在法国的两大权力中心之一。这位教会人士评价贝德福德说：“既明智又慷慨，既受敬畏又受爱戴。”乔纳森·萨姆申（Jonathan Sumption）在他关于百年战争的最后几卷巨著中有一个精彩的观察。他说，贝德福德在法国维持了一支常备军，引用萨姆申的话说，
something which England would not have a gain until the time of Oliver Cromwell. And there is something slightly of Cromwell, I think, about Bedford. He's very robust. He's also a very civilized man. So it's noted that he speaks good French. He's a great patron of French churches, of French artists. He's married to the sister of Philip the Good, Anne. so he has a French wife.
“直到奥利弗·克伦威尔时代，英国才再次拥有这样的军队。”我认为贝德福德身上确实有一点克伦威尔的影子。他非常强硬。他也是一个非常文明的人。所以人们注意到他法语说得很好。他是法国教堂、法国艺术家的伟大赞助人。他娶了“好人菲利普”的妹妹安妮，所以他有一位法国妻子。
So he is absolutely able to keep the French administration on side. Because even though most of the military are English, the civilian government is French. And the fact that Bedford is so impressive, this is why people like Couchon are so happy to serve him. It's the best rule of France ever had, Tom. Meanwhile, what of the Dofair, or in fact, Charles the Seventh, as he now properly is, if you're backing the House of Valois. But the thing is nobody is calling him, Charles and Severn. They're all still calling him the Dauphan. Because he seems an insubstantial figure still. And so I think the Dauphin, recognizing this has been doing his best to try and balance that out. So he's got himself a queen. So he has married a girl called Marie. And she is the daughter of a very, very impressive woman. She's called Yolande. And she is the Dowager Duchess of Enjou. So the enjavans, I mean, they're a very serious dynasty. And she's probably the most formidable woman in the kingdom. So she's described by one fan as the wisest and most beautiful princess in Christendom.
所以他绝对能够让法国行政部门站在他这一边。因为尽管大多数军人是英国人，但文官政府是法国人。贝德福德如此令人印象深刻，这就是为什么像科雄这样的人如此乐意为他服务。这是法国有史以来最好的统治，汤姆。与此同时，王储，或者事实上，查理七世，如果支持瓦卢瓦王朝的话，他现在的情况如何？但问题是没人叫他查理七世。他们仍然叫他王储。因为他看起来仍然是一个虚无缥缈的人物。所以我认为王储意识到了这一点，一直在尽力平衡这一点。所以他给自己找了个王后。他娶了一个叫玛丽的女孩。她是位非常、非常了不起的女性的女儿。她叫约兰德（Yolande）。她是安茹太公爵夫人（Dowager Duchess of Anjou）。所以安茹人，我的意思是，他们是一个非常严肃的王朝。她可能是王国中最令人生畏的女性。所以一位粉丝形容她是“基督教世界中最聪明、最美丽的公主”。
She's seen all the other princesses. Well, I think, I mean, I think she clearly is a very smart woman. And she is famously gorgeous. And she's a very keen supporter of the Arminiaks. And so that's why she has swung behind the Dofair, given the Dofah, her daughter to be his wife. And in July 1423, she is absolutely delighted. when her daughter gives the Dofant a son who is called Louis and now Yolande is all in.
她见过所有其他公主。嗯，我想，我的意思是，她显然是一位非常聪明的女性。而且她以美貌著称。她是阿马尼亚克派的坚定支持者。所以这就是为什么她转向支持王储，把她的女儿嫁给他作为妻子。1423年7月，她感到非常高兴，当她的女儿为王储生下了一个儿子，名叫路易。现在约兰德全力以赴了。
I mean, she really wants to see her grandson, king of all France. And so you have, you know, you've got the infant Henry the 6th, you've got the infant Louis as Charles VIII's son. The House of Lancaster, the House of Valois, both have everything to play for. So let's fast forward a few years because this doesn't change straight away. So if we go forward seven years, right? So it's 1429, so at the end of the 1420s.
我的意思是，她真的想看到她的孙子成为全法国的国王。所以你有，你知道，你有婴儿亨利六世，你有婴儿路易作为查理七世的儿子。兰开斯特王朝，瓦卢瓦王朝，都有机会一搏。所以让我们快进几年，因为这不会马上改变。如果我们向前推进七年，对吧？所以是1429年，也就是1420年代末。
So the dauphin is still very much on the outside, isn't he? So he's still called the dauphin because he basically doesn't, he's not really the king of France. He hasn't been crowned because Rass. Well, he hasn't been crowned in Rast is miles away in the English-held territory. There's no prospect of getting there. And the English very much seem to have the upper hand, don't they? Yeah. And crucially, the English have maintained.
所以王储仍然处于非常边缘的地位，不是吗？他之所以还被称为王储，是因为他基本上还不是真正的法国国王。他还没有加冕，因为兰斯……好吧，他没能在兰斯加冕，那里远在英国控制的领土之内。根本没有机会到达那里。而且英国人似乎确实占据了上风，不是吗？是的。而且至关重要的是，英国人保持了。
their reputation for military invincibility. So the Dofa had actually gone north of the Loire, which effectively constitutes the frontier between Lancasterian France and Valois held France. And he had tried to rest Normandy, which is the central territory under English rule, back from Bedford. But it all goes disastrously wrong. So the English and the French meet outside a town called Vernay, and 8,000 of the Dauphin's men are either killed or captured by the Duke of Bedford and his army. And among those who are captured is the young son of the Duke of Alonsohn who had died at Agincourt. This little boy, he's grown up, he's now 15, is his first battle, and immediately he's been taken captive. And so this is terrible. But
他们军事上不可战胜的声誉。所以王储实际上已经到了卢瓦尔河以北，这实际上构成了兰开斯特统治下的法国和瓦卢瓦统治下的法国之间的边界。他曾试图从贝德福德手中夺回诺曼底，那是英国统治下的核心领土。但一切都极其糟糕。英国人和法国人在一个叫韦尔讷伊的小镇外相遇，王储的8000名士兵要么被杀，要么被贝德福德公爵及其军队俘虏。在被俘的人中，有在阿金库尔战役中阵亡的阿朗松公爵的幼子。这个小男孩已经长大了，现在15岁，这是他的第一场战斗，结果立刻就成了俘虏。所以这太可怕了。但是
what's even worse is that Bedford now officially confiscates his duchy. and Bedford himself becomes the Duke of Alonsoor. And so effectively, I mean, this is terrible for Alonsohn, because he's captive, you know, he needs to raise money for ransom and all his land has gone. So it's, he's in desperate straits. So most of France now, north of the River Loire, so we're talking about sort of north central France, is now controlled by either the Duke of Bedford for the English or Philip the good, the Duke of Burgundy, right?
更糟糕的是，贝德福德现在正式没收了他的公国，而贝德福德本人成为了阿朗松公爵。所以实际上，这对阿朗松来说太可怕了，因为他被俘了，你知道，他需要筹集赎金，而且他所有的土地都没了。所以他处于绝望的境地。所以现在卢瓦尔河以北的大部分法国，也就是我们所说的中北部法国，现在要么由英国人的贝德福德公爵控制，要么由勃艮第公爵“好人”菲利普控制，对吧？
And the English are now thinking, do we drive south of the Loire? And actually the Duke of Bedford says to his captains, right, the next stage of the war is we will force our way across the Loire and we will take the fight to the Dofand, his sort of fly-bitten, two-bit capital of Bourge, and we'll finish this. Yes. And the key to essentially breaching the Loire, which at this point is much broader than it is today, I mean, it's a serious barrier. So they essentially need to secure a really, really strategically significant crossing point. And the obvious place is Aulon, which is the northernmost settlement. So the Loire kind of curves northwards. O'Leon is at the northernmost point of this curve, and therefore nearest to Paris, which is under English control.
英国人现在在想，我们要不要打到卢瓦尔河以南？实际上，贝德福德公爵对他的指挥官们说，好吧，战争的下一阶段是我们将强行渡过卢瓦尔河，我们将把战火烧到王储那个被跳蚤叮咬、二流的布尔日首都，我们要结束这一切。是的。而突破卢瓦尔河的关键在于，卢瓦尔河在这一点上比今天宽得多，我的意思是，它是一道严重的屏障。所以他们基本上需要确保一个具有真正战略意义的渡口。最明显的地方是奥尔良，它是最北端的定居点。卢瓦尔河在这里向北弯曲。奥尔良位于这个弯道的北端，因此离巴黎最近，而巴黎处于英国的控制之下。
And if the English can capture Aulior, then the road south will be open, and they can follow it into the bowels of the kingdom of Borge. And effectively, Bedford hopes that would then be game over for the Dauphin. So preparations are made. Summer of 1428, a huge English army disembarks at Calais, evidence of the ability of the English state to kind of raise forces, something vastly in excess of anything that the Dauphin can do. And by November, English forces have constructed siege walls and fortifications around with the goal of starving the city into submission. And the English commander is a guy called
如果英国人能占领奥尔良，那么通往南方的道路就会打开，他们可以顺着这条路进入布尔日王国的腹地。实际上，贝德福德希望那将是王储的末日。于是准备工作开始了。1428年夏天，一支庞大的英国军队在加来登陆，这证明了英国国家动员军队的能力，其规模远远超过了王储所能做到的任何事情。到了11月，英军已经建造了围城墙和防御工事，目标是让这座城市因饥饿而投降。而英国指挥官是一个叫
William de la Pole, who is the Earl of Suffol. And he had been one of Henry's key commanders in the conquest of Normandy. Another serious and formidable person. Absolutely. And with a particular talent for capturing cities, because that was the main focus of the conquest of Normandy. They had to capture it, you know, places like Ruat and so on. He has two lieutenants. One of them is the hard man of early 15th century England, a guy called John Talbot, who's an absolute animal. I mean, he's played by Ray Winston, is he not? Yeah, he's played by Ray Winston, or the most kind of terrifying rugby player that you can imagine.
威廉·德·拉·波尔的人，他是萨福克伯爵。他曾是亨利征服诺曼底时的关键指挥官之一。又一个严肃而令人生畏的人。绝对是。而且他特别擅长攻占城市，因为那是征服诺曼底的主要重点。他们必须攻占它，你知道，像鲁昂之类的地方。他有两个副手。其中一个是15世纪早期英国的硬汉，一个叫约翰·塔尔博特的人，他简直是个野兽。我的意思是，他是由雷·温斯顿扮演的，不是吗？是的，他由雷·温斯顿扮演，或者你可以想象的最可怕的橄榄球运动员。
Vinny Jones. There's a part for Vinny Jones. Vinny Jones, that's who he is. Well, he's not Vinny Jones, actually, because he is very aristocratic. So I think rugby is slightly better. He's kind of posh, but, you know, he'll rip your arm off. He's played by Lawrence Delalio. Exactly.
维尼·琼斯。有一个角色适合维尼·琼斯。维尼·琼斯，就是他。好吧，他其实不是维尼·琼斯，因为他非常有贵族气质。所以我认为橄榄球运动员稍微好一点。他有点时髦，但是，你知道，他会把你胳膊扯下来。他由劳伦斯·达拉利奥扮演。没错。
He's Lawrence Delalio. And he has a younger partner in the command. It's a guy called Lord Scales. He's only 23. He's also a very, very hard man. I mean, he's killed a lot of his enemies already by this point. He's played by Morrow Otoge. Yeah, I guess.
他是劳伦斯·达拉利奥。他还有一位年轻的指挥伙伴。是一个叫斯凯尔斯勋爵的人。他才23岁。他也是一个非常、非常强硬的人。我的意思是，到目前为止，他已经杀了很多敌人了。他由马罗·伊托杰扮演。是的，我想是吧。
I guess. Yeah, on the BBC. Yeah, exactly. So these are serious men. O'Leon is in serious straits and by early 1429 basically everyone in Europe is thinking, the English have got this
我想是吧。是的，在BBC上。是的，没错。所以这些人都是狠角色。奥尔良处于严重的困境中，到1429年初，欧洲基本上每个人都在想，英国人已经赢定了。
so we have the record of a Venetian merchant in Burgundy and he writes to a family member in Venice if the English take Aureon they will have no difficulty in making themselves lords of all France and sending the dofow packing to beg his bread at arms houses
所以我们有在勃艮第的一位威尼斯商人的记录，他写信给威尼斯的一位家庭成员说，如果英国人占领了奥尔良，他们将毫无困难地使自己成为整个法国的主人，并把王储打发走，让他去济贫院乞讨面包。
and it looks like the city will fall because every French attempt to relieve the siege has been beaten off, kind of almost disdainfully. The Dauphin has exhausted his reserves both of cash and of men. And as a result, people who previously had been backing him in the Loire Valley are starting to, you know, they sense where the wind is blowing and they're starting to kind of go over to the English. Meanwhile, around Orleans, week by week, day by day, ever more siege lines are going up. The city seems doomed. There seems no prospect of
看起来这座城市要陷落了，因为法国每一次试图解除围城的努力都被几乎轻蔑地击退了。王储已经耗尽了他的现金和人力储备。结果，之前在卢瓦尔河谷支持他的人开始，你知道，他们感觉到了风向，开始倒向英国人。与此同时，在奥尔良周围，一周又一周，一天又一天，越来越多的围城线正在建立。这座城市似乎注定要灭亡。似乎没有任何希望
of relieving it in any way. And so effectively, if Allio is going to be saved for the House of Valois, it is going to take a miracle. But Dominic, from where could such a miracle possibly come? I don't think we've ever had a more exciting cliffhanger. Come back after the break and we will find out. In my own village, they call me Jeanette. Since I came into France, I have been called Jan. Of my third name, I know nothing. I was born in the village of Dom Remy. So that is the deposition given by the woman that we call Joan of Arc.
以任何方式解除围困。所以实际上，如果奥尔良要为瓦卢瓦王朝保存下来，那将需要一个奇迹。但是多米尼克，这样的奇迹可能从何而来呢？我想我们从来没有过比这更令人兴奋的悬念了。休息后回来，我们将揭晓答案。在我的村子里，他们叫我珍妮特。自从我来到法国，我就被称为让娜。至于我的第三个名字，我一无所知。我出生在栋雷米村。这就是我们称之为圣女贞德的女人所作的证词。
And she gave that on the 21st of February 1431 at her trial in Ruins on charges of heresy. And we can tell a lot from the records of that trial. And also a second inquiry, which was staged by the French themselves in 1456, because that was trying to overturn the completely legitimate verdict of that first trial and to rehabilitate Joan. The records are very detailed, aren't they, Tom? And they have an immediacy and a humanity that really brings her alive as a character.
她在1431年2月21日于鲁昂的审判中给出了这些证词，罪名是异端。我们可以从那次审判的记录中看出很多东西。还有第二次调查，那是法国人自己在1456年组织的，因为那是为了推翻第一次审判完全合法的判决，并为贞德平反。记录非常详细，不是吗，汤姆？它们有一种直接感和人性，真正让她作为一个角色活了起来。
Yeah. I mean, you've got to give all kinds of caveats, and everybody who writes about Joan of Arc always does. So, Joan's words in these records are rendered into Latin by the clerks who are recording them. And obviously, she is on trial for her life. And she's an uneducated girl being pressed by very educated men who, let's face it, want to kill her. And even the witnesses at her rehabilitation, they also have their own agenda, lots of incentives to kind of tailor what they're reporting. So all of those caveats have to be borne in mind. That said, we know about Joan and we can hear her in her own words in a way that is incredibly unusual for people from the middle ages, full stop.
是的。我的意思是，你必须给出各种警告，每个写圣女贞德的人总是这样。所以，贞德在这些记录中的话是由记录它们的书记员翻译成拉丁文的。显然，她正面临生死审判。她是一个没受过教育的女孩，被那些受过高等教育的人逼问，说实话，他们想杀了她。即使是她平反时的证人，他们也有自己的议程，有很多动机去修饰他们所报告的内容。所以所有这些警告都必须牢记在心。话虽如此，我们了解贞德，我们可以以一种对于中世纪的人来说极其罕见的方式听到她自己的话，句号。
Well, especially young women from peasant background. You never hear from them. Absolutely. Because that is what's really extraordinary. You know, we're not hearing a Duke or an abbot. or a king talking. We are hearing a young peasant girl. And when you read the records of the trial, her personality completely shines through. I'm going to lay my cards on the table. Dominic, you may disagree. But she is witty.
嗯，尤其是来自农民背景的年轻女性。你从来听不到她们的声音。绝对是。因为那才是真正非凡的地方。你知道，我们听到的不是公爵、修道院院长或国王在说话。我们听到的是一个年轻的农家女孩。当你阅读审判记录时，她的个性完全闪耀出来。我要摊牌了。多米尼克，你可能不同意。但她很风趣。
She is courageous. She's incredibly charismatic. And it's these records, I think, that have really burnished her story in the modern period. She's up there with Emma Hamilton and Unity and Infid in. your pantheon top. So she's not an aristocrat like Unity Mipford. She, you know, she's not a courtesan like Emma Hamilton. And she's kind of unique.
她很勇敢。她非常有魅力。我认为正是这些记录真正擦亮了她在现代时期的故事。她在你的万神殿中与艾玛·汉密尔顿和尤妮蒂·米特福德并列。所以她不像尤妮蒂·米特福德那样是贵族。她，你知道，她不像艾玛·汉密尔顿那样是交际花。她是独一无二的。
So there's a brilliant book that I read when I was at a very impressionable age by Marina Warner, I think it came out in the early 80s called Joan of Arc, the image of female heroism. And in her introduction, Marina Warner says of Joan that, you know, she's not a queen, she's not a courtesan, she's not a beauty, not a mother, not an artist of one kind or an nor until the extremely recent date of 1920 when she was canonized, a saint, to reiterate, she is a female teenage peasant girl. And when we hear her speak, I think what we're also hearing all the more loudly is the silence of all those kind of numberless peasants from medieval
我年轻时读过一本玛丽娜·华纳写的精彩的书，我想是80年代初出版的，叫《圣女贞德：女性英雄主义的形象》。在引言中，玛丽娜·华纳谈到贞德时说，你知道，她不是女王，不是交际花，不是美女，不是母亲，不是某种艺术家，也不是直到1920年她被封圣之前，她都不是圣人，重申一遍，她是一个十几岁的农村女孩。当我们听到她说话时，我认为我们听到的更响亮的是中世纪所有那些无数农民的沉默。
Christendom whose words no one ever thought to record. This is very moving from you. Well, I do find it a moving story. I find it a powerful story. and I find the fact that we can hear her words, it is a crucial part of what makes this story so fascinating, I think. So let me just pledge to the listeners that I will suspend my natural skepticism and cynicism for at least the next 30 seconds.
基督教世界里那些话语从未被记录下来的人。你这番话很感人。嗯，我确实觉得这是一个感人的故事。我觉得这是一个强大的故事。而且我认为我们能听到她的话这一事实，是让这个故事如此迷人的关键部分。所以让我向听众保证，我将在接下来的至少30秒内收起我天生的怀疑和愤世嫉俗。
Let's talk about her family. Well, I mean, you are going to have lots to be skeptical about. I mean, there is no question about that. Okay, brilliant. Love it. So let's talk about what we know. Let us start with her family. So we know that her father was called Jacques Dark,
让我们谈谈她的家庭。嗯，我的意思是，你会有很多值得怀疑的地方。我的意思是，毫无疑问。好的，太棒了。喜欢。所以让我们谈谈我们所知道的。让我们从她的家庭开始。所以我们知道她的父亲叫雅克·达尔克，
Jack of Arc. Yeah, and so that's where the name Xandark comes from. Her mother is Isabel. We know that her mother must have been pious because Joan says, From my mother, I learned my Lord's Prayer, my Hail Mary and my Creed. And we know that she had a sister and three brothers, two of whom will feature in this story. And we've described them as peasants, but they're not the underclass. They're not the lowest of the low, are they?
雅克·达尔克。是的，这就是“让娜·达尔克”（圣女贞德）这个名字的由来。她的母亲是伊莎贝尔。我们知道她的母亲一定很虔诚，因为贞德说：“我从母亲那里学会了主祷文、圣母经和信经。”我们知道她有一个姐姐和三个兄弟，其中两个将出现在这个故事中。我们把他们描述为农民，但他们不是底层阶级。他们不是最底层的人，对吧？
They are. And she's actually, it's often said she's a shepherd girl. I mean, that's one of the most common things that people say about her, but she wasn't. They were more respectable than that, right? No, and I think the idea that she's a shepherd, there are kind of biblical echoes there. That's why it's suited to people who were praising her to say it. But Joan herself was having none of it. She regarded shepherdesses with a great deal of snobbery.
他们是。而且她实际上，人们常说她是牧羊女。我的意思是，这是人们关于她说的最常见的事情之一，但她不是。他们比那更体面，对吧？不，我认为她是牧羊人的想法，里面有一种圣经的回声。这就是为什么那些赞美她的人说这话很合适。但贞德本人并不买账。她对牧羊女怀有极大的势利眼。
Oh, no, she's Virginia Woolf. So in her trial, she said, I learned to spin and to sew, and she challenged the women of Rouen to spin and sew better than her. And she does this because to be a seamstress, to be a spinner, a spinster is, you know, you're on a higher level than a shepherdess. Right. So she's from Dom Remy. And the location of this place is interesting and really important because it is, dare I say, liminal. It's on the frontier between two different places, champagne and L'Hrain, the river Murs runs through it.
哦，不，她是弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫。所以在她的审判中，她说：“我学会了纺纱和缝纫。”她挑战鲁昂的妇女们，让她们纺纱和缝纫得比她更好。她这样做是因为成为一名女裁缝、一名纺纱工、一名老处女，你知道，你的地位比牧羊女高。对。所以她来自栋雷米。这个地方的位置很有趣，而且非常重要，因为它，我敢说，是处于边缘的。它位于两个不同地方的边界上，香槟和洛林，默兹河穿过它。
And the fact that it's on a frontier is important because it's basically drawn into the civil war by definition. because the village is pro-Dofan, but the next village is pro-Baghundian. And the villagers fight each other quite often, don't they? And people are badly wounded or even killed in the fighting between these two villages. Yeah, and also, Domaini is on the front line of the English attempt to annex the region and pacify it completely. So as Joan is growing up, there are more and more English raiding parts. parties who are starting, you can see them on the horizon, and they are fighting with rival
它位于边界这一事实很重要，因为它基本上被定义为卷入了内战。因为这个村庄支持王储，但下一个村庄支持勃艮第。村民们经常互相打斗，不是吗？在两个村庄的战斗中，人们受了重伤甚至死亡。是的，而且栋雷米处于英国试图吞并该地区并彻底平定它的前线。所以当贞德长大时，越来越多的英国突袭队开始出现，你可以在地平线上看到他们，他们正在与效忠于王储的敌对公司作战。
companies who are loyal to the dauphin. And this notion of free companies, something we've talked about throughout our series on the Hundred Years' War, these are kind of semi-freelance bodies of men, lots of whom are pretty criminal. And so it's very, very frightening. It's kind of Wild West situation, the bad guys galloping into town. we know that this does happen to Dom Remyi and to other villages around. So when Joan was 11, her cousin was killed by a cannonball that was fired into the church
这种自由公司的概念，是我们整个百年战争系列中谈论过的，这些是某种半自由职业的武装团体，其中很多人相当犯罪。所以这非常、非常可怕。这有点像狂野西部的局面，坏蛋们骑马冲进镇子。我们知道这确实发生在栋雷米和周围的其他村庄。所以当贞德11岁时，她的表弟被一颗炮弹击中，那颗炮弹射进了他避难的邻村教堂。
of a neighbouring village where he'd taken refuge. And then the church in Dom Remy itself is burnt down and most of the village with it at least once. And so for Joan, the ringing of church bells, which are sounded when danger is threatening, you know, this would have been something with which she was very, very familiar. So, in the summer of 1428, so this is the same year that the English are landing to head down for the siege of Ullior, an Anglo-Bugundian army embarks on the systematic conquest of the region.
然后栋雷米本身的教堂被烧毁了，大部分村庄至少被烧毁了一次。所以对于贞德来说，教堂钟声的敲响，那是危险临近时发出的声音，你知道，这一定是她非常、非常熟悉的东西。所以，在1428年夏天，也就是英国人登陆前往奥尔良围城的同一年，一支英勃联军开始了对该地区的系统性征服。
All the dauphinist strongholds fall, all except one. And this is a fortress called Vauculeur, which is very formidable, has a large garrison, and it's under the command of a nobleman by the name of Robert de Baudricor. De Beaudricourt has very good connections at the French court, and specifically with the house of Enjou, so that is Yolande and her dynasty. And de Baudrecault is very brave, but he's also brutal and unscrupulous. And you have to assume that basically you have to be brutal and unscrupulous if you're going to hold a fortress against the onslaught of the English and the Burgundians.
所有支持王储的据点都陷落了，只有一个除外。这是一座叫沃库勒尔的堡垒，非常令人生畏，有大量的驻军，由一位名叫罗贝尔·德·博德里库尔的贵族指挥。德·博德里库尔在法国宫廷有很好的关系，特别是与安茹家族，也就是约兰德和她的王朝。德·博德里库尔非常勇敢，但也残忍且肆无忌惮。你必须假设，如果你要守住一座堡垒以抵御英国人和勃艮第人的猛攻，你基本上必须残忍且肆无忌惮。
All right. So that's the background. So Joan has been growing up in Dormorimi, in this very much. very violent, frightening, dangerous, divided landscape. And how does that shape her character, would you say? Well, I think that it leads her to identify the dofair as the kind of the ultimate guarantor of France's stability. I think she comes to have a sense that if only the dofair could be put on his throne
好吧。这就是背景。所以贞德是在栋雷米长大的，在这个非常暴力、可怕、危险、分裂的景观中。你会说这如何塑造了她的性格？嗯，我认为这导致她将王储视为法国稳定的终极保障。我认为她开始有一种感觉，如果王储能被送上王位，
and crowned and the English could be driven out, then everything would be fine. And Marina Warner is brilliant on this in her book, talking of Jane. She had a natural inclination for clear-cut situations with identifiable centres of authority. The King's supreme position and her magnetic attraction for it bear witness to this taste. She'd like to unity, organisation, rallied groups. So she's basically a kind of working-class Tory. That's what she wants. She wants order and she wants royal rule.
并加冕，英国人能被赶走，那么一切都会好起来。玛丽娜·华纳在她的书中谈到贞德时非常出色。她天生倾向于有明确权威中心的清晰局面。国王的至高地位和她对它的磁性吸引力证明了这种品味。她喜欢统一、组织、集结的团体。所以她基本上是一个工人阶级的保守派。这就是她想要的。她想要秩序，她想要王权。
But she's also intensely pious. And again, you can see why. you know, you're growing up surrounded by this violence. And the sounding of the bells is what alerts you to danger coming. So I guess just subliminally, you would come to associate bells with the hope of safety, with the prospect that warnings may be coming. And so bells seem to have been very, very important to her, to have played a very, very strong role in her emotional and spiritual life. And so we know from the court records that, um, because a friend of hers recorded it, you know, at her rehabilitation trial, that once the sacristan forgot to ring the bells for Compline, and Joan told him off and said, go and go and ring them. And if she was out in the fields and she heard the bells ringing, she would always kneel. They have an immense significance for her. And I think that you said she's pious. I mean, she clearly is. But I think what the bells, when she hears the bells, she is being reminded
但她也非常虔诚。同样，你可以看出原因。你知道，你在这种暴力中长大。钟声的敲响是提醒你危险即将来临。所以我猜潜意识里，你会把钟声与安全的希望、警告可能即将来临的前景联系起来。所以钟声似乎对她非常、非常重要，在她的情感和精神生活中扮演了非常、非常重要的角色。所以我们从法庭记录中知道，嗯，因为她的一个朋友记录了下来，你知道，在她平反审判时，有一次圣器收藏员忘记敲响晚祷的钟声，贞德责备他说，去，去敲响它们。如果她在田野里听到钟声响起，她总是会跪下。它们对她有巨大的意义。而且我认为你说她虔诚。我的意思是，她显然是。但我认为钟声，当她听到钟声时，她是在被提醒
and reassured that amid all the violence of the age, there is. a link to God and his saints and that they are close to her. They care for her and that her prayers will be heard. Okay. And she can't, she can't read and write. She's illiterate. But you mentioned God and his saints. She's pretty obsessed with some of these saints, isn't she? And she regards them. I mean, they, we did an episode about, a long time ago about Catherine of Sienna, about somebody, another teenage girl whose proximity, you know, who had this almost a obsessive, this totally transcendent and dominating fixation with, you know, that being the bride of Christ and all this kind of thing. And there's, sometimes I think about Joan,
并确信在那个时代所有的暴力中，有一个与上帝及其圣徒的联系，而且他们就在她身边。他们关心她，她的祈祷会被听到。好的。她不会读写。她是文盲。但你提到了上帝及其圣徒。她对其中一些圣徒非常着迷，不是吗？她把他们视为……我的意思是，他们……我们很久以前做过一期关于锡耶纳的凯瑟琳的节目，关于另一个人，另一个十几岁的女孩，她的亲近，你知道，谁有这种几乎强迫性的、这种完全超越和主导的固定观念，关于，你知道，成为基督的新娘之类的东西。有时我想关于贞德，
there's something similar, again, a teenage girl, a sort of fixation on this case, on the personality of three saints in particular. There are certainly similarities, and we'll maybe come to them later in the series with Catherine Siena, but I think there are also differences. And the key one is that Joan, unlike Catherine, as we've said, is illiterate. And therefore, she is dependent on both stories and images. And we know she loves stories. She loves chivalric romances, for instance. She's very familiar with these.
有类似的东西，同样，一个十几岁的女孩，对这个案例，对三个特定圣徒的个性有一种固定观念。肯定有相似之处，我们以后可能会在系列节目中谈到锡耶纳的凯瑟琳，但我认为也有不同之处。关键的一点是，贞德与凯瑟琳不同，正如我们所说，是文盲。因此，她依赖于故事和图像。我们知道她喜欢故事。例如，她非常熟悉骑士传奇。
But she also loves stories of the saints. And I don't think she's unusual in her familiarity with them. The leading saints, the most famous saints, are as familiar to children growing up in medieval Europe this time as kind of singers or sports stars would be to teenagers today. But there are three, it seems, who are the particular focus of her devotion. And the first of these is really unsurprising. It's St. Michael, who is the great warrior archangel, the captain of heaven, who in the book of Revelation, throws down Satan.
但她也喜欢圣徒的故事。我不认为她对他们的熟悉程度有什么不寻常。在那个时代，最著名的圣徒对于在欧洲中世纪长大的孩子来说，就像今天的青少年对歌手或体育明星一样熟悉。但似乎有三位是她特别崇拜的对象。第一位真的不足为奇。那是圣米迦勒，伟大的战士大天使，天堂的队长，他在《启示录》中将撒旦扔了下去。
And for the French, he is the great emblem of their resistance. So we've said how Henry V conquered all of Normandy. That's not quite true, because playing the role of Asterix's village in this scenario is Saint-Michel, the mount of St. Michael, the great monastery there on this island, and that is holding out against the English. And so the fact that it is dedicated to St. Michael, it emphasizes the way in which this warrior archangel is presumed by the French to be fighting on their side. And so the Dauphin commissions two great standards, both of which show St. Michael trampling down the serpent, trampling down Satan. And more specifically, and one of the reasons why Joan is
对于法国人来说，他是他们抵抗的伟大象征。所以我们说过亨利五世是如何征服整个诺曼底的。那不完全正确，因为在这个场景中扮演阿斯泰利克斯村庄角色的是圣米歇尔，圣米迦勒山，那个岛上的伟大修道院，它正在抵御英国人。所以它献给圣米迦勒这一事实，强调了这位战士大天使被法国人假定为站在他们一边战斗的方式。所以王储委托制作了两面伟大的旗帜，两面都显示圣米迦勒践踏蛇，践踏撒旦。更具体地说，贞德绝对熟悉他的原因之一是，他是她成长地区的守护神。所以，圣米迦勒，非常重要。所以你可以看出这一点。然后有两位女性圣徒。你可以看出为什么她们会吸引一个十几岁的女孩，也许，嗯，这些是因抵抗、勇气而闻名的圣徒。此外，我还发现她们有点因为她们的受害者身份或殉道而显得严厉，对吧？她们殉道而不是放弃贞洁。所以我猜对贞德来说，她们是勇气和独立的象征。其中一位，亚历山大的圣凯瑟琳，同样，不仅仅是贞德崇拜她。她可能是那个时代最受喜爱的圣徒。实际上，贞德的姐姐，在她还是个女孩时就去世了，名字叫凯瑟琳。对。所以亚历山大的凯瑟琳，她本应嫁给一个异教徒罗马皇帝之类的。她在轮子上被折磨，因此有了凯瑟琳轮，那种烟花。每个人都认为她很棒。然后另一个是，我必须承认，我不熟悉她的事迹，那就是安条克的圣玛格丽特。嗯，我非常熟悉她，因为她被一条龙吞下，然后又被吐了出来。古怪。她成了助产士的守护神。而且，萨迪，我的妻子，当然，是一名助产士。
definitely familiar with him. He's the patron saint of the region in which she is growing up. So, St. Michael, very significant. So you can see that. And then there's two female saints. And you can see why they would appeal to a teenage girl who perhaps, well, these are these are saints who are noted for their resistance, for their courage. Also, I found being harsh a little bit for their victimhood or their martyrdom, right? They're martyred rather than surrender their virginity. So I guess to Joan, they are emblems of courage. independence. And one of them, St. Catherine of Alexandria, again, it's not just Joan who's devoted to her. She's probably the best-loved saint of the age. And actually, Joan's sister, who died while she was
所以这里有大新闻。但她是另一位因拒绝放弃贞洁而殉道的圣徒。所以这显然是贞德所警惕的。但也有一个关于圣玛格丽特的故事。她非常渴望学习经文等等，以至于她伪装成男人进入了一家修道院。哦，一个说明性的细节。非常说明性的细节。所以关于圣徒的这一点，我认为这对于那些不太熟悉中世纪基督教世界的听众来说，进入他们的脑海是非常重要的。对于像贞德这样的人来说，圣徒的意义在于，正如你所说，她是文盲，他们占据了15世纪欧洲具体、物理、非常暴力、残酷和危险的世界，与超越的世界、纯洁、天堂的秩序之间的空间，他们基本上在两者之间进行调解，不是吗？这就是为什么，对于像她这样的人来说，他们有如此宇宙般的……直接的存在感。是的。
still a girl, had been called Catherine. Right. And so Catherine and Alexandria, she was meant to be married to a pagan Roman emperor or something. She's broken on a wheel, hence the Catherine wheel, the firework. And everyone thinks she's brilliant. And then the other one is, I have to admit, I'm not familiar with her work, and that is Margaret of Antioch. Well, I'm very familiar with her because she was swallowed by a dragon and then regurgitated. Quaky. She's become the patron saint of midwives. And, Sadie, my wife, of course, is a midwife.
和意义。他们活在她的心中，就像他们活在她的脑海中一样，大概。是的，我认为天堂秩序、超自然秩序的亲近感是贞德在成长过程中完全认为理所当然的事情。其他人也认为理所当然，但她……我的意思是，事实上，关于她听到钟声时跪下的事情。你认为她甚至在第一次超自然造访之前就特别虔诚吗？特别虔诚，特别容易受影响，特别有想象力，特别自信
So very big news here. But she's another saint who was martyred for refusing to surrender her virginity. So that's clearly something that Joan is alert to. But also, there is a story of St. Margaret. She's so desperate to learn the scriptures and so on that she enters a monastery disguised as a man. Oh, a telling detail. Very telling detail. So just on this thing about the saints, I think this is massively important for listeners
也是，我想。好的。所以我认为是一个非常独特的女孩，大概。是的，我的意思是，说实话，你并没有把她推销为一个玩伴。但实际上，她一起玩的人和其他农民孩子非常不同，对吧？因为当她13岁时，实际上说明性的是，当她基本上进入青春期时，我想，1425年，
who are not super familiar with the world of medieval Christendom to get into their heads. The point of the saints for somebody like Joan, who is, as you said, illiterate, is that they occupy a space between the concrete, physical, very violent and brutal and dangerous world of 15th century Europe, and the transcendent world, the purity, the order of heaven, And they basically mediate between those two things, don't they? And that's why, for someone like her, they have such cosmic... Immediate presence. Yeah.
发生了什么事，所以告诉我们发生了什么。嗯，她在审判中自己描述了。声音第一次出现在一个夏日的中午，在我父亲的花园里。她特别指出，这个声音来自村教堂的方向，所以那是
And significance. They live in her heart as much as they do in her mind, presumably. Yeah, I think that the closeness of the heavenly order, the supernatural order, is something that Joan, as she is growing up, completely takes for granted. Other people take it for granted too, but she is... I mean, by the fact, the stuff about her kneeling when she is... hears the bells. She is peculiarly pious, do you think, even before her first supernatural visitations. Cicely pious, peculiarly impressionable, peculiarly imaginative, peculiarly self-confident
钟声敲响的地方。而且它沐浴在光芒中。贞德坚持对那些非常怀疑的审判官说，从一开始她就明白这个声音是好的、值得的，它是上帝派来引导她的声音。她从未放弃过那种断言，那种信念。随着时间的推移，她开始明白它不是上帝本人的声音，而是一位天使的声音，
as well, I think. Okay. So I think a very distinctive little girl, probably. Yeah. I mean, you're not really selling her, to be honest, as a playmate. But actually, the people she's playing with are very different from the other pussant children, right? Because when she's 13 years old, actually tellingly, when she's basically entering adolescence, I think, 1425,
但起初，我想，她并没有将其特别等同于圣米迦勒，也没有等同于凯瑟琳或玛格丽特，尽管从长远来看她会。起初，我不认为她有这种感觉。嗯，我们会看到的，因为这些声音是什么以及贞德认为这些声音是什么的问题是一个复杂而迷人的问题，我认为它会在她的一生中演变。但绝对清楚的是，她将其体验为真实的，她基本上与这个起初是声音，然后变成多个声音的声音进行对话，但她与这些声音的对话方式与她与其他人对话的方式一样，即以一种非常直率、嗯、坚定的方式。所以如果声音
something happens, so tell us what happens. Well, she described it herself in her trial. The voice first came at noon on a summer's day in my father's garden. And she specified that this voice came from the direction of the village church, so that's
告诉她一些她不同意的事情，她会告诉它们，好吧，这很不寻常，因为大多数听到声音的人，嗯，实际上疯狂地，我们谈论的最后一个听到声音的人是开膛手杰克案的嫌疑人之一。但当人们听到声音时，他们就会做声音告诉他们的事情。他们不会与声音争论。这是贞德与那个时代其他女性神秘主义者之间的对比，正如我们将要谈到的，对于贞德来说，这些，你知道，这些有点像你可能通过耳机听到的声音之类的。根据她的描述，这并不完全是一种神秘体验。这简直就像你在听西奥。
where the bells would be rung from. and that it was bathed in light. And Joan insisted to inquisitors who were very skeptical about it, that right from the beginning she had understood this voice to be good and worthy and that it was a voice sent from God to guide her. And she never let go of that assertion of that conviction. And in time, she came to understand it as the voice, not of God himself, but of an angel,
很像，嗯，是的，我们从西奥那里得到的信息，这些声音起初，它们为她提供精神指导，但随后它们开始越来越多地给她一个政治使命，在几个月甚至几年里，这个使命变得清晰起来。所以起初，声音给她一种模糊的指示，她应该去王储那里，骑在他前面，把英国人赶出法国。然后它变得更精确，她应该带领王储去兰斯，让他加冕。然后1428年底，到那时奥尔良围城的消息已经传到栋雷米，声音告诉她骑马去奥尔良，打破英国的围城。
but she did not, to begin with, I think, identify it with St. Michael specifically, nor with Catherine, nor with Margaret, although in the long run she would. To begin with, I don't think she had a sense. Well, we will see because the question of what these voices are and what Joan thought the voices are is a complex and fascinating one, and it will evolve, I think, over the course of her life. But what is absolutely clear is that she experiences it as real and she essentially has conversations with this initially it's a voice then it becomes voice multiple voices but she has conversations with these voices in the way that she has conversations with everyone else namely in a kind of very forthright um and kind of firm manner so if if the voices
而声音，我的意思是，这些是告诉一个十几岁女孩的疯狂事情。但声音说，好吧，别担心。你知道，我们会引导你。在这个我们给你的使命中，我们会全程支持你。如果你按照指示去做，那么从长远来看，整个法国确实会从英国人手中解放出来，而这种解放将是向世界证明你确实肩负着上帝使命的终极证据。你提到贞德，你知道，她反驳声音，但她从未怀疑
tell her something that she doesn't agree with she tells them that okay that that is unusual because most people who hear voices um i mean actually madly the last person we talked about hearing voices was one of the suspects in the Jack the Ripper case. But when people hear voices, they then do what the voice tells them. They don't argue back with the voices. And this is a contrast, as we'll come to, between Joan and other female mystics of the age, is that for Joan, these, you know, these are kind of like voices that you might hear through headphones or something. It's not entirely a mystic experience from her description of it. It's literally like you listening to Theo.
它们的真实性，对吧？她从未质疑这些声音可能是恶魔，或者她可能被误导。因为它们是好的。她有一种它们是好的感觉。她对声音告诉她的事情有完全的信心，而且她实际上，我再次认为这很有趣，
quite like well yes the messages that we get from Theo and these voices to begin with they offer her spiritual guidance but then increasingly they start to give her a political mission and over the course of the months and then the years this mission comes to be clarified so to begin with the voices are giving her a kind of vague instruction that she should go to the dauphin and ride in front of him and drive the English out of France then it becomes more precise she should lead the Dauphan to Rass and have him crowned there. And then late in 1428, by which time the news of the siege at Aureon will have reached Dom Rémy, she's told by the voices to ride to Aureon and to break the English siege.
她刚刚进入十几岁，她发了贞洁誓言，所以她要保护她的贞洁，她的父母为她安排了一个未婚夫，她说：“你走开，我对你不感兴趣。”然后我们到了1428年底，所以你知道，
And the voices, I mean, these are mad things to tell a teenage girl. But the voices say, well, don't worry. You know, we will guide you. We will support you throughout this mission that we've given you. And if you do as instructed, then in the long run, the whole of France will indeed be liberated from the English, and this liberation will be the ultimate proof in the eyes of the world that you are indeed on a mission from God. And you mentioned that Joan, you know, she answers back to the voices, but she never doubts
事情对王储和法国事业来说看起来非常危险，这就是她决定的时候，“好吧，我要做声音告诉我的事情，我要投入进去，开始把英国人赶走的工作。”是的，但你怎么开始呢？你是一个农家女孩，你知道，在事情的边缘，你要去哪里？
their veracity, right? She never questions whether the voices might be demons or she might be misled. Because they're good. She has a sense of them as good. She has total confidence what the voices are telling her and she actually again I think it's interesting
她真正能去的地方只有一个，那就是沃库勒尔，这是该地区唯一一个在罗贝尔·博德里库尔指挥下仍然为王储坚守的堡垒。她告诉她的父亲，这就是我要去做的。她的父亲惊呆了。我的意思是，她拒绝了她父亲为她选择的结婚对象，他已经很愤怒了。而且他一直做着噩梦，梦见贞德和武装人员一起逃跑。这意味着，你知道，他基本上担心她会开始在性方面表现不端，她会和
that she's just entered her teens she takes a vow of chastity so she's going to protect her virginity her parents have lined up a fiancé for her she says you're out I'm not interested in you and then we get to late 1428 so you know
一个士兵一起逃跑。所以她现在16岁，什么？她大约16岁。我的意思是，任何父亲，你知道，你16岁的女儿来找你说，我基本上要逃跑，像，加入军队。好吧，我要去，我要去一个满是男人的堡垒。是的。而且，你知道，去告诉他们一些胡言乱语，你会非常、非常担心。你会感到不安。所以问题是，贞德是一个逃跑者。你知道，她故意无视她父亲的命令，逃到了沃库勒尔，那里充满了暴力的士兵和男人。
the things are looking very dicey for the dauphin the French cause and this is the point when she decides right I'm going to do what the voice is telling me I'm going to get stuck in and begin the work of driving out the English. Yeah, but how do you begin? You're a peasant girl, you know, on the edge of things, where are you going to go?
她去找博德里库尔，他是一个相当肆无忌惮的人，我们已经说过了。所以有点，相当危险的人。她去找他，解释了她的使命。他，第一次他说：“你疯了，走开。”第二次，“你疯了，走开。”她仍然在沃库勒尔徘徊。她无视德·博德里库尔所说的话。所以1429年1月，
There's only one place she really can go, and that is Vaucule, which is the one fortress in the region that is still holding out for the Dauphin under the command of Robert Baudrecourt. And she tells her father, this is what I'm going to go and do. Her father is appalled. I mean, he's already outraged that, you know, she's turned down the man that her father has chosen for her to marry. And also he's been having these nightmares in which he sees Joan running away with men at arms. And the implication of that is that, you know, essentially he's worried that she is going to start misbehaving sexually, that she's going to run away
德·博德里库尔来到贞德一直住的沃库勒尔的房子，他带了当地的牧师一起来。他告诉牧师：“这个女孩被邪灵附身了，驱逐这个邪灵。”但贞德只是在牧师面前跪下，责备牧师说：“你在做什么？”
with a soldier. So she's now 16, what? She's about 16 years old. I mean, any father, you know, your 16-year-old daughter comes to you and says, I'm basically going to run off and, like, join the army. Well, I'm going to go, I'm going to go to a fortress full of men. Yeah. And, you know, know, and come up, tell them some cock and bull story, you'd be very, very worried. You'd be perturbed. So the thing is, Joan is a runaway. You know, she deliberately ignores her father's orders and runs away to Vocalur, full of, full of violent soldiers and men.
“你听过我的忏悔。你知道我确实站在天使这一边。”所以牧师说：“好吧，你知道，她没有被附身。我在这里无能为力。”所以贞德站起来，转向德·博德里库尔。第三次，她说：“带我去见王储。”这一次，博德里库尔让步了。这可能是他自己的主动，也可能是他收到了他两位地区领主的消息。
And she goes to Baudricor, who's, he's a quite unscrupulous person, we've already said. So kind of, quite a dangerous man. She goes to him and she explains her mission. And he, first time he says, you're mad, go away. Second time, you're mad, go away. she's still hanging around in Bocahleur. She's ignoring what DeBodricor has said. So in January 1429,
这些人是一个叫查尔斯，洛林公爵的人，和勒内·德·安茹，而勒内·德·安茹是王储岳母约兰德的次子。所以为什么这两个家伙，他们是严肃的人，你知道，贵族，权力掮客，
DeBodricor comes to the house in Vokalur where Joan has been staying and he has brought the local priest with him. And he tells the priest, this girl is possessed by an evil spirit, exercise the evil spirit. But Joan just kneels in front of the priest and reproaches the priest and says, what are you doing?
为什么他们会鼓励连德·博德里库尔本人，另一个严肃的人，都认为是一个疯女孩，只是有疯狂、古怪想法的人。
You've heard my confession. You know that I am literally on the side of the angels. And so the priest says, well, you know, she's not possessed. There's nothing I can do here. And so Jones stands up and she turns to de Baudrecourt. And a third time, she says, take me to the Dauphin. And this time, the Baudrecault relents. And this might be on his own initiative or it might be that he has received word from his two regional overlords.
为什么他们纵容这个？嗯，洛林公爵查尔斯当时病得很重，他收到消息说有一个女孩声称肩负着上帝的使命。这并不非常不寻常。你知道，每隔一段时间，通常是女孩，但有时男孩也会出现，声称他们有来自上帝的信息。他们通常有能力创造不可思议的奇迹。所以我认为洛林公爵查尔斯希望也许贞德会治愈他。但贞德说：“不，我不会那样做。我不能治愈任何人。”而且在这点上，她再次显得不寻常。她做的唯一奇迹就是她的使命。
And these are a guy called Charles, the Duke of Lorraine. and René of Anjou and René of Anjou is the second son of Yolande, the mother-in-law of the Dauphin. So why do these two guys who are serious people, you know, aristocratic people, power brokers,
你知道，她不是到处去治愈病人，或者，你知道，类似的事情。是的，是的，是的。她将其斥为无稽之谈。我怎么能治愈任何人？那不是我能做的。查尔斯并没有因此被冒犯。事实上，他相当印象深刻。他给了她一些钱，还给了她一匹马。
why on earth would they be encouraging what clearly Dabodricor himself, another serious person, thinks, is a sort of loony girl who's just got mad, crack-bought ideas.
因为，当然，她需要一匹马。如果她要骑马一直到王储那里，他在卢瓦尔河以南的沙隆，大约300英里远。至于勒内·德·安茹，你知道，我们说过他是王储王后的兄弟，他确实有赌注确保王储留在战斗中。他很可能认为，正如约兰德可能认为的那样，“好吧，你知道，我的意思是，让我们试试。我们有什么可失去的？”我想是这样。
Why do they indulge this? Well, Charles of Lorraine is very ill at the time, and he's been brought word that there's this girl claiming a mission from God. And this isn't massively unusual. You know, every so often, it's usually girls, but sometimes boys as well, will appear claiming that they've got messages from God. And they are often capable of performing incredible miracles. And so I think that Charles of Lorraine hopes that perhaps Joan will heal him. But Joan says, no, I'm not going to do that. I can't heal anyone. And in this, again, she's unusual. The only thing she does miraculous is her mission.
他们为什么要纵容这种事呢？当时洛林公爵查理病得很重，有人告诉他有个女孩声称自己肩负着上帝的使命。这种情况并不罕见。你知道，时不时就会有人——通常是女孩，有时也有男孩——出现并声称他们收到了上帝的旨意。他们往往还能展现出不可思议的神迹。所以我认为洛林公爵查理是希望贞德或许能治好他。但贞德说，不，我不会那样做。我无法治愈任何人。在这一点上，她又显得与众不同。她唯一展现的神迹就是她的使命。
You know, she's not going around healing the sick or, you know, anything like that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And she dismisses it as nonsense. Why would I be able to heal anyone? Let's not what I can do. And Charles is not offended by this. In fact, he's rather impressed. And he gives her some money and he gives her a horse.
你知道，她并没有到处去治愈病人，或者做类似的事情。是的，是的，是的。她把这种想法斥为无稽之谈。我怎么可能治愈任何人呢？那不是我能做的事。查理并没有因此感到被冒犯。事实上，他反而印象深刻。于是他给了她一些钱，还送了她一匹马。
Because, of course, she's going to need a horse. If she's going to ride all the way to the dauphin, who's in Chalon just south of the Loire, which is about 300 miles away. As for René of Vangue, you know, we've said he's the brother. of the Dauphin's queen, he really has a stake in ensuring that the Dauphan stays in the fight. And he may well think, as Yolande may well have thought, well, you know, I mean, let's try. What have we got to lose? I suppose.
因为当然，她需要一匹马。如果她要一路骑马去见王储，王储当时在卢瓦尔河以南的希农，距离大约有300英里。至于勒内·德·旺格，你知道，我们说过他是王储王后的兄弟，他确实有理由确保王储坚持战斗。他很可能和约兰德的想法一样，觉得，好吧，我们试试看。反正我们也没什么可失去的，我想。
And there's probably also, do you think it's a slight element of like, come on, let's just get rid of her, tell her to go? No, I don't think so. You don't think so? You think they believe in it? I think they actively think we've got nothing to lose. She may be what she says she is. I think they are very, very interested in what Joan has to say, because I think they're desperate. DeBodricor definitely still has reservations because what happens now is a very controversial
而且可能还有一点，你觉得他们是不是有一种“算了吧，干脆打发她走，让她离开”的想法？不，我不这么认为。你不这么认为？你觉得他们真的相信她？我认为他们是真心觉得反正也没什么可失去的。她可能确实如她所说的那样。我觉得他们对琼要说的话非常非常感兴趣，因为我认为他们已经走投无路了。德·博德里库尔肯定仍有保留意见，因为接下来发生的事情是一个非常有争议的
development in Joan's story. Joan says, okay, I'm going on this mission. I need male clothing if I'm going to go. Right. And DeBodricor gives her male clothing, but we know from later source, which describes his reaction to it, that he handed this. male clothing over only with the utmost repugnance, to quote the court records. And this isn't surprising because the 15th century, it's fair to say, is not a trans-friendly era. So, cross-dressing
琼故事中的发展。琼说，好吧，我要去执行这个任务。如果我要去，我就需要男装。没错。德·博德里库尔给了她男装，但我们从后来的资料中得知，这些资料描述了他对此的反应，他是在极度厌恶的情况下才交出这些男装的，引用法庭记录的话说。这并不令人惊讶，因为公平地说，15世纪并不是一个对跨性别者友好的时代。所以，女扮男装
is seen as being an abomination unto God. And that is because it is specifically condemned in the book of Deuteronomy in the Old Testament. The woman shall not wear that, which pertaineth unto a man. So we've said that Joan is very pious, but when she wants to, she's perfectly capable of ignoring a direct biblical dictate. So I don't want to plunge into my skeptical amateur psychology too much straight away, but to say she's entered her teens, she's taken a vow of chastity, protecting her virginity is incredibly important to her, and she now says she wants to dress as a man. There are, you know, implications for this, maybe let's say, secular, secular-minded listeners might draw implications from this about what is actually nagging at her.
被视为对上帝的亵渎。这是因为《旧约》中的《申命记》明确谴责了这种行为。“妇女不可穿戴男子所穿戴的”。所以我们说过琼非常虔诚，但当她想这样做时，她完全有能力无视直接的圣经训诫。所以我不想太快陷入我那怀疑论的业余心理学分析，但可以说她已经进入青春期，她发了贞洁誓言，保护童贞对她来说极其重要，而现在她说她想穿男装。这其中有，你知道，一些暗示，也许我们可以说，世俗思想的听众可能会从中推断出到底是什么在困扰着她。
We should wait until we've told her whole story and listened to what she actually has to the trial before kind of trying to work out what might have been going on here. But I hear you, Dominic. I hear you. Anyway, so she has her outfit of male clothes. She has her hair cropped into the kind of, you know, the nightly pudding bowl that anyone who's seen the painting of Henry V will recognize. She's got her horse.
我们应该等到讲完她的整个故事，并听听她在审判中到底说了什么，然后再去揣测这里可能发生了什么。但我听到了，多米尼克。我听到了。总之，她有了男装。她的头发被剪成了那种，你知道，亨利五世画像中那种骑士式的布丁碗发型。她有了马。
She's been given a sword, which anyone with nightly pretensions needs. And de Baudricor has given her two pages and intriguingly four men at arms. So her father's dream has come true. Oh, no. Her father must be gutted. And of course, they are there to guard her because they are going to be riding across what is effectively bandit territory. And this also is, you know, you could say, well, it's a sensible precaution for any girl
她得到了一把剑，这是任何有骑士抱负的人所必需的。德·博德里库尔还给了她两个侍从，有趣的是，还有四个武装人员。所以她父亲的梦想成真了。哦，不。她父亲一定很心碎。当然，他们在那儿是为了保护她，因为他们将要穿过实际上是土匪横行的地区。这也是，你知道，你可以说，这对任何女孩来说都是一个明智的预防措施
who is going to ride 300-odd miles through a war zone. to disguise the fact that she is female. Although it has to be said that at no point does Joan ever justify her cross-dressing in those terms. And the clear implication, which in time she will make explicit, is that her voice has told her to dress in male clothes. That it's not a question of practicality and pragmatism. She never says that. She never says that. And the male clothing, as we will see in our next episode, serves for her.
要骑行三百多英里穿过战区。掩盖她是女性的事实。尽管必须指出的是，琼在任何时候都没有用这些理由来为她的女扮男装辩护。而明确的暗示，她以后会明确表达出来，是她的声音告诉她要穿男装。这不是实用性和务实的问题。她从没这么说过。她从没这么说过。而且正如我们下一集将看到的，男装对她来说有其作用。
Well, we will tease out what it means to her, but it is clearly something very, very spiritually, psychologically, symbolically significant to her. But why? What does it have to do with her mission? What are her voices? These are all questions that we will explore, perhaps, or we start exploring in our next episode when Joan arrives at the court of the Dauphin and reveals to the Dauphan the mission that she has been given by God. Very exciting. And actually, I have to say an absolutely fascinating story. I remember when you were researching this, Tom, you were saying to me, this is one of the most intriguing stories that done on the rest of history. It's certainly panning out that way. So if you want to find out what happens when Joan arrives at the Doverhouse Court, whether she succeeds in saving Orleans from the English, we're going to be telling the whole
好吧，我们会剖析这对她意味着什么，但这显然对她来说在精神上、心理上和象征意义上都非常非常重要。但为什么呢？这和她的使命有什么关系？她的声音是什么？这些都是我们将在下一集中探讨的问题，或者说开始探讨的问题，届时琼将抵达王储的宫廷，并向王储揭示上帝赋予她的使命。非常令人兴奋。而且我必须说，这是一个绝对引人入胜的故事。我记得当你研究这个的时候，汤姆，你对我说，这是《余下的历史》中最引人入胜的故事之一。它确实正朝着那个方向发展。所以，如果你想知道琼抵达王储宫廷后会发生什么，她是否能成功从英国人手中拯救奥尔良，我们将讲述整个
story in the next three episodes. And if you're a member of the Restis History Club, you can hear those episodes straightaway. If you would like to start the new year on an inspiring and exciting note, then do join the Restis History Club at the Restis History.com because we are planning all kinds of exciting benefits for you this year, not just the usual ad-free listening and early access to series, but all sorts of thrilling bonus series to come for club members only. However, the key thing is Joan of Arc and what will happen next in her story. And that is what we will be investigating next time. Au-voir. Au-voir. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
故事在接下来的三集里。如果你是《余下的历史》俱乐部的成员，你可以立即收听这些剧集。如果你想以鼓舞人心和令人兴奋的方式开始新的一年，那么请加入《余下的历史》俱乐部，网址是 RestisHistory.com，因为我们今年为您计划了各种令人兴奋的福利，不仅是通常的无广告收听和抢先观看系列节目，还有各种为俱乐部会员准备的激动人心的额外系列节目。然而，关键是圣女贞德以及她故事的后续发展。这就是我们下次要调查的内容。再见。再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。